we do have a voicemail number two one
nine two david p sometimes we get
constructive criticism sometimes we get
unconstructive criticism and sometimes
it's just straight-up hate and that's
what it is today take a listen to this
you truly are know yet most respect
freaks anti-american yep complete freaks
right which doesn't show any resemblance
of this country or how this country was
formed I feel sorry for you I pray for
you
thank you and God forgive you right
the number of people that have said they
are praying for me because I am so
misguided if prayer works I should be
doing really really well because of the
number of people that are that are
praying for me I I don't even know what
else to say about this you know what
line I'm gonna use when I want to insult
someone now I'm gonna preface whatever I
have to say with with all those with all
due respect you are an American and it's
guided freaks and I'm praying for you to
192 david p if you have something you
want to chime in with on today's bonus
show we talked about the bush the book
keeper of auschwitz previously he has
died before entering jail and i have
some thoughts on this which i'll discuss
on today's bonus show National
Geographic is also acknowledging its
past racist coverage we will talk about
that and after Bruno Mars has been
accused of cultural appropriation black
celebrities are coming to his defense
and this is also a story that I am very
very interested in so we've got a great
bonus show two ways to access the bonus
show number one become a member at david
pakman.com slash membership method
number two become a patron to the tune
of at least five US dollars per month at
patreon.com slash david pakman show both
methods will get you
access to the bonus show and of course
we have a 40% discount code running
right now for membership that coupon
code is vote ha I'm sorry vote soon 18
vote soon 18 all lowercase all one-word
no-spaces will save you 44 0 percent off
of the membership of your choice might
as well do it right and then the show
wouldn't be ending now you would still
have the bonus show to look forward to I
know I'm looking forward to it